- We have time for just one more story.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
So, you've all probably heard
of Cabbage Patch dolls, right?
- [Audience] Yeah!
- You've heard of Cabbage Patch?
We're around the same age, nice.
People went absolutely nuts for them
when they came out in 1983,
the year after I was born.
It was almost cool.
The demand was insane though.
These were everywhere.
There's a new documentary detailing it all
called "Billion Dollar Babies:
"The True Story of the
Cabbage Patch Kids."
It's in theaters November 24th
and we actually have the
director on the line right now.
So everybody say hi to Andrew Jenks.
Come on!
(audience clapping)
What's up, Andrew?
So, why this story?
- You know, it's crazy 'cause
when you go on YouTube even
and just look up Cabbage Patch Kids,
you just see these insane
riots in malls and stores
and people going absolutely insane.
And so, I started to
wonder like, why was that?
What was going on?
And one thing about
the Cabbage Patch Kids,
which people may remember, is
the element of imagination.
They built a hospital for
the Cabbage Patch Kids
called Babyland General.
People dressed up in the
hospital with thousands of dolls
as doctors and nurses,
and there was ambulances.
And so, it was just this
element of really believing
that they're not even dolls, they're kids.
And in fact, people were going so crazy
that the company that was
making Cabbage Patch Kids
had to stop running commercials
because the government sued them
saying that the commercials
were harassing children
since they were promoting a doll
that you could no longer get in stores.
So, they actually had to
stop running the commercials.
They announced that
and that made people
wanna get them even more.
So it just added to the craze.
- Oh my God, what is wrong with humanity?
Of course, we wanted it more
now that somebody said
there's none available.
So, well, that's intriguing.
I did not know any of that actually.
Everybody, to see more about
the Cabbage Patch Kids craze,
check out Andrew's film,
"Billion Dollar Babies."
It's in theater's November 24th.
Thank you so much, Andrew.
I'm liking your post now.
(audience cheering)
All right, y'all.
Well, we've hit that point
when we usually give our guest $1,000
courtesy of our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
But today, that's gonna go
to one lucky person in this audience.
So anybody want some money?
(audience cheering)
Keep your eye on this monitor.
Someone's face is gonna pop up.
(audience cheering)
Faces, faces.
First of all, your hair looks fantastic.
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Like a walking party.
What's your name?
- Lisa.
- [Kelly] Lisa, how are
you gonna spend the grand?
- I don't know.
(audience laughs)
- Well, Lisa, have a little fun with it.
Yeah, have a little fun with it.
- I have four kids.
I'm sure I can figure it out.
- Okay.
I have kids too.
Spend it a little on them.
Spend a little on yourself.
Do this for me.
A mama of four.
God bless, let's give you a round.
(audience clapping)
Well, thank you Lisa.
Thank you to all our guests this hour:
Tom Blyth, Rachel Zegler,
Josh Andres Rivera,
Hunter Schafer, Nina
Jacobson, Francis Lawrence.
Y'all have a great day, and if
it's not, try and change it.